são vozes foi descobrindo que só temos
duas opções daqui quando acabar essa
apresentação ou vocês têm certeza que
nós estamos malucos ou saímos todos
malucos daquilo que entendemos nós somos
um estúdio em 5 um grupo de pensadores
no ramo da arquitetura somos quatro nós
devemos partilhar convosco uma
experiência que foi muito interessante
até certo ponto engraçada que aconteceu
nos nossos últimos dois anos de trabalho
[Música]
e muitas vezes na família no trabalho
nunca
[Música]
é melhor e faz ainda como vou deixar
pouco não estamos a ter um governo com o
ônus é incluir a porque nós julgar os
indecisos e dois do mundo mas não ser é
claro né e lugar os ciganos quadra 14
casa e os quadros são quatro por 3
metros quadrados e mais de dois terços
da bica estrelas mas também sou muito
além
mais uma vez a perguntar será que assim
será que o homem não vai vir mais três
coisas o véu amarelo azul vermelho
amarelo e azul
eu acrescento atrás dele dentro do
investimento uma fortuna o tempo
investido tem seis metros feminina no
mundo essas coisas que nós falamos
em uma conversa com eles agora
o dia é nós começamos a questionar
acerca da área em que nós nos
encontramos que a arquitetura e
começamos a fazer perguntas básicas do
que é uma casa o que é ter uma casa o
que é não ter uma casa
o que que é a arquitetura para a
humanidade
quais são as oportunidades que a
arquitetura criada com uma de nós
estamos hoje aqui falar pra vocês num
lugar como este arquitetônico mas
principalmente quais são as limitações
que a arquitetura nos dá
com todos esses escritórios prédios
hotéis estradas é tudo hoje é produto da
arquitetura o que quero que todo mundo
está a deixar ver o que é que tu não
está a deixar viver então mergulhar a
fundo nessas questões fez nos irrita
infinitivamente tentar procurar
respostas que algumas é de alguma forma
de inspiraram e e falávamos falamos de
colecionar fizemos uma boa coleção do
pensamento
então um dia desde um cliente ligou
revertê-la o escritório e disse que
queria uma casa numa tela língua e nós
vamos disputar aqui uma boa oportunidade
de pôr em prática vários daqueles
pensamentos relacionados
e foi nessa oportunidade que nasceu
nosso projeto do laos né
e não parece mas isto é uma casa e que
isto é uma é uma casa né
na verdade a do laos é uma introdução à
nossa intenção na arquitetura
laís presenciamos provavelmente a mais
sublime experiência com algum cantor
pode sentir a mais mágica se vocês me
permitirem dizer que quer assistir um
projeto do lado por si próprio é como se
nós só tivesse um dia descobrir a casa e
ela já existia
há várias épocas e nós como qualquer
pessoa se estamos com projeto com o
resultado final uma casa redonda fora do
comum
nunca tínhamos visto isso né nós
próprios tinham ficou sentado mas a
gente até a casa onde sentimos muito
confiantes porque sabemos que aquela
casa resultou de alta de horas altas
horas de pensamento e depois de algum
tempo para ser honesto muito tempo
decidimos ligado ao nosso cliente e
dinei também uma boa notícia a notícia
já acabamos a primeira fase do projeto e
gostaríamos que viessem de ver
nós queremos dizer uma coisa queremos
dizer primeiro que já sabemos o que quer
que tudo significa para nós e
principalmente como podemos alcançar
resultados com potencial de desenvolver
uma inteira espécie
então nós chamamos nossos clientes
estamos a mostrar olha olha isto não
sabemos como é que aconteceu
ó sei lá estou eu eo cliente está tipo e
privilegiado de poder viver passado a
vida dele é espaços jamais presenciaram
mais sentidos é mais visto e sem que de
repente a responsabilidade dos jogos e
começou a aquecer na área dizer até uma
boa proposta mas onde está a minha
cozinha americana
essa casa está muito redonda mel de uma
piscina de 25 metros que isso tem que
apresentar se eu contrato um arquiteto
no mínimo quer dois pisos no mínimo
vocês já devem imaginar que estava na
nossa cabeça uma vez que nós não
estivemos sob controle o resultado final
na verdade a técnica que nós usamos para
fazer esta casa foi combinar as
condições ambientais sol vento e tudo
andamento com gráficos que fizemos de
tudo o ambiente pudéssemos dizer com
condições humanas de dormir comer e já
sabemos respirar mas as condições do
programa
o cliente não apresentou o número de
agregados familiares e que será casas e
escritórios
nós combinamos essas três condições e
tirarmos na nossa a nosso ego aquilo que
nós gostamos e vimos que nasceu isto
então nós não tínhamos o que dizer ao
nosso cliente tanto que começamos a
tentar por piscina de 25 metros a casa
rejeitava
ponhamos mais não sei quantos quartos em
cima dos pisos a cada dia não então foi
nessa experiência que até certo ponto
que foi um fracasso porque não
conseguimos convencer o cliente com uma
coisa que nós achávamos que era tão
óbvia casa era supera e nós cada vez que
me falar com nossos amigos que vem
ajudar seu amigo que passava sempre um
escritor viu o que é isto um ovo uma
casa de um cliente e sangue estão
frustrados que eles pensavam que nós lá
no estúdio só fazemos caderno donna é
nossa moda mas são jorge o escritório
desenvolve causando ondas até os nossos
amigos não perceberam o processo que nós
passávamos né
então essa foi uma experiência que nós
decidimos ficar compartilhar com vocês
porque foi aqui que nós que damos à
grande eureka
fizemos a descoberta mais importante das
nossas vidas mil foi de queijo da palha
a nossa descoberta
está a ver essa fórmula consiste em
gracinha órgão realidade é um dos
objetivos da anatel definiu quatro atrás
ou seja a forma mais fácil lançar um dos
núcleos do projeto não pode partir das
nossas pela mesma temporada ele ia do
dia e todas as outras para 66 anos será
a mesma escutei que buscar as melhores
cotações da sé nova guiné que o sol o
vento a água é que acreditamos que as
soluções criadas por mim então tá bom
humor nem nos momentos nós pudermos
proferir o resultado sempre será meu
nome mas não vou comemorar com os carros
claro sou o cara que corta o inventor
você vai ser quando um curso e quando a
beleza do v
há uma limitação que ele tinha aquela
época ele se encontrava ou e trouxe um
cara que é através disso o bb os fácil
nessa hora é de pura nós vemos todos os
dias que eu espero falando das sopas
tratamentos países com notação
financeira justifica nossa cobrança é
vender o próprio à tona uma coalização
dúvida aquela altura e hoje a trocaçao
você sempre terá ligações perigosas mais
cara que a do homem ea utilização de uma
ferramenta uma limitação do espaço
coberto para colaborar com muito gosto
e bem é em jeito de finalizar nós
queremos trazer um desafio pra vocês
nós sabemos que cada um que está nesta
sala trabalha numa ferramenta própria ou
música ou arquitetura o advogado a cia
ou qualquer uma das ferramentas nós
queremos desafiar vos a repensar e ea
ver de que forma a ferramenta que vocês
com o som para trabalhar dentro de todos
os dias de que forma essa ferramenta nos
ajuda a respirar melhor
não desenvolvemos mais através de
limitações de ferramentas porque se não
vamos cair no erro de construir mais
ferramentas vai realmente quer dizer o
homem para inspirar precisa com mês e
tudo que é de repente precisa de um
sítio porque está com frio tem roupa tem
casas depois o arquiteto ver que a casa
caiu
engenharia civil engenharia civil da fei
decoração entre o itacaré economia então
nós se não percebermos se não percebendo
qual é o problema e o que nós queremos
com a humanidade
vamos continuar a desenvolver mais e
mais e mais ferramentas e isso
condiciona condiciona alunos ao real
evolução da espécie
nós não vamos ver mais coisas não vamos
voar então cada ferramenta que temos
hoje aqui na sala é responsável por
ajudar o américa respirar melhor é
responsável por fazer com que o homem
amanhã
lembre que andou com quatro patas
lembre-se que via duas cores e os 93
vamos lembrar que vimos três vamos
lembrar que andávamos com 24 de agora
até transportados
então o desafio trazemos hoje é que
pensemos vemos tais mil passos para trás
e repensarmos de que forma a música
ajuda nos a respirar melhor que forma eu
como comunicadora mara ajudando as
pessoas a respirar melhor
então essa foi a nossa presença
só espero que tenham gostado e sim
[Aplausos]